obviously a lot of people are still
surprised by the outcome of Tuesday's
election it's pretty much the only thing
people have been talking about here's
something interesting you're gonna like
this I found out this morning that one
of our stagehands Neal he's worked for
me for a bunch of years he was a big big
Hillary supporter he's just returned
from a week-long meditation retreat he
still doesn't know who won the election
it's crazy how how is that possible okay
how was that even possible
okay I'll tell you on the retreat they
had no phones no TV no internet he
hasn't had any contact with anyone so
when I heard this okay I immediately had
Neil placed in a soundproof box
immediately okay I know you're the boss
but that seems like a weird thing okay
Andy I did it for a reason I wanted to
preserve him in his state of blissful
ignorance all right okay he's in this
perfect beautiful state let's bring him
out just to give all of us a look at
someone who still doesn't know all right
what happened here he is our stagehand
Neil let's get him out
[Applause]
wadn't onin look look it is look at his
face he's so innocent he doesn't he
doesn't have a clue about what happened
oh I remember that look he's so naive I
envy him actually yeah that's a look
from a simpler purer more innocent time
really something cool d'oeuvre yeah no
kidding I'd give anything to be that guy
right now yeah well I guess we all just
ya know put the newspaper down put the
newspaper down put it down
I'll go it's too late II saw it no no
he's upset no no Billy Billy give him
the gas give him the gas now
getting the gas booty
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
phone and I I think you did the right
thing by putting him to sleep no Andy
he's dead it's for the best he's better
off now sorry
he's he's he's dead but he's fogging up
the I know I was noticing that too seems
like there's air coming out of his nose
yeah just curious how long that actor
can keep that up all right let's
dominate enough he's still going he's
good we have a great show tonight I am
absolutely thrilled their comedy legends
two of the funniest people ever to have
lived John Cleese Eric Idle are on the
show
[Applause]
hater he's not dead now he's going to be
[Laughter]
you